nothing good happens in nightclubs after
1: in the morning I am patient zero I Am
the Doctor of late night parties that's
one of my expertise it's this sort of
messy sloppy fights and kissing people
you shouldn't stumbling all over the
place and stuff if you go out and you
don't drink and you go home at 1:00 in
the morning I think you probably get to
capture about 80% of the enjoyment of
the event that you would have done had
you have drank pre-drinks gone out done
the whole thing if alcohol wasn't so
widely distributed I think people would
ask a lot more questions when you've
taken a little bit of time away from it
and you look at it in the harsh light of
day the effects that alcohol gives you
aren't that enjoyable and it's been
folded into people's lives through
tradition and through just anchoring
bias and continuation